COLE: You ready to
reel a fish in, Willow?
WILLOW: Yeah.
COLE: It's been a while, huh?
COLE: We'll see.
Well, today, Timber
and Willow, Willow mostly,
they both been
asking to go fishing.
So, see if we can just
pull one winter king in.
Kings, they got
good fat content,
especially this time of year.
Oh, and we don't get sunshine.
Salmon's our Vitamin D.
Oh, yeah, I'm
starting to mark bait.
Timber, are you okay
to drive for a minute?
TIMBER: Yeah.
COLE: You drive and
I'll throw out the,
the sneaker pole
out the back here.
See if we can't get
these girls hooked on a king.
TIMBER: Cross your fingers!
COLE: I am Cole Sturgis.
I live in Thorne Bay, Alaska
on Prince of Wales Island.
In Southeast Alaska.
My family and I live in
our two-story house that
floats in the ocean.
My oldest is Timber.
My middle daughter is Willow,
and we have a little
two-year-old that's, uh, Cedar.
And when you're a logger,
you tend to name
your kids after trees.
(laughs)
Coming from Montana, I've
never been in the ocean really.
Until I found a
job cutting timber.
And didn't take us
long at all to figure out
we're heading North.
For me, everything
in Thorne Bay's unique.
The peace, the quiet of it.
There's no rat race here.
It's a rainforest.
Things grow here
like I've never seen.
It's a magical place.
We try to sustain on
what the ocean gives us.
And this land
around here provides us.
If we don't stay on
top of the food chain,
we starve.
To be proficient up here,
you have to be stubborn.
I'm kind of a jack of all
trades and a master of none.
I don't know much,
but I know a lot.
You know?
Nice and easy. There you go.
TIMBER: We're under one.
COLE: Good job.
It's a big advantage, teaching
your children how to drive.
I can be manning the poles.
Timber knows to
take us on course.
Need one now
we're just waiting now.
Good job, girls.
Really makes a person proud.
That your
children are that cool.
Yeah, good duck coming in.
Let's see if
there's a king in here.
TIMBER: Yeah, I like that.
COLE: This is the greatest
thing I've been gifted with.
To raise my girls.
And help them and teach them.
(gusting winds)
(shivering)
COLE: What's wrong, Willow?
COLE: Timber, you're cold?
TIMBER: Yeah.
COLE: All right, we'll
circle back towards the house.
I'll just go out
and check tomorrow,
maybe we'll get some fish.